[Music]
I'm Jeff floor from CBS Saturday morning
welcome to the dish coffee lovers
Rejoice today we travel far and wide to
find the perfect cup of joe in Brooklyn
we meet a self-described activist
entrepreneur shedding light on the rich
culture and flavor of Vietnamese coffee
and we visit a San Francisco Cafe famous
for their Irish coffee but first come
with us as we follow the enchanting
Aroma of espresso all the way to Italy
where Seth Doan hit the streets of
Naples to experience the Perfect Pour
[Music]
the vibrant Southern Italian city of
Naples seems to run on espresso
is a very exciting city is any of that
due to its love for coffee yes this is
packed in here it's like a temple and
coffee here is like a religion Cafe
gambrinos was established before Italy
was back when Naples was a kingdom we're
talking about coffee you know it's just
like talking about the pizza you know
it's part of our tradition and this
Marcelo utsi offers high-end tours of
his City and says this is a regular
stock espresso simply called coffee here
takes about 30 seconds to brew a little
less than that to drink
okay please next time take your time
Moreno faino works for Italian coffee
Powerhouse ili how many cups of coffee
do you think you have in a day working
here
roughly 10.
he says it's a real shame to Simply
knock it back
think about what happened before the 50
beans were selected how many people was
involved in preparing the Red Cap of
espresso and then you have to appreciate
the balance the right level of
bitterness and the sourness and
sweetness
there's so much to know that Illy
developed a university of coffee at its
headquarters in the northeastern Port
City of Trieste there are more than 140
rules that can affect the final result
in the cafe yes rules Barista Stefano
giannini is a sort of coffee professor
at alien what exactly is espresso if you
consider from Latin expression it means
Under Pressure this is the way we
extract the coffee
Italians invented this highly calibrated
method of preparation but first the
beans must be roasted and ground just
right an art in itself
Ely Imports coffee beans from about two
dozen different countries and at any
given time has around a hundred thousand
bags of it on hand that is enough to
brew more than 650 million cups of
coffee
that seems just about enough to fuel the
city of Naples which brings us back I
said hey how are you
this is your local spot yes this is it
there is a bit of competition here among
different Italian cities who has the
best coffee how can you compete with our
coffee it's impossible
indeed espresso is brewed under pressure
with a fair dose of passion and pride
good
up next the taste of Vietnamese coffee
via a Brooklyn Roastery stay with us
[Music]
we often associate coffee coming from
Powerhouse producers like Brazil or
Colombia but did you know that Vietnam
is actually the second largest grower of
coffee beans in the world Nancy Chen met
an entrepreneur on a mission to give
these lesser-known beans a little more
Buzz
all right
something's Brewing on the first floor
of this building tucked among the
warehouses of industrial Brooklyn
the complex and caffeinated flavors of
Vietnam carefully roasted to their
chocolate caramelized Peak under the
watchful eye of Sarah Nguyen oh this is
heavy it's 30 pounds okay there you go
pour all in pour it all in all of it as
the CEO of nguin coffee Supply nguin
says Timing is Everything just one
minute can make all the difference for
these beans oh
really smell the sugar it's yeah the
sugars are in a Burly pop
so we're currently now at a 410 degrees
Fahrenheit so when it's hotter it's
developing much rapidly at this point
second because every 5-10 seconds will
change the profile of The Bean nue knows
the importance of striking while the
bean is hot when the self-described
activist entrepreneurs started the first
specialty Vietnamese coffee company in
the United States coffee from Vietnam
was both nowhere and everywhere
I didn't know that Vietnam was the
second largest grower of coffee beans in
the world yes and honestly Nancy I think
it's because of lack of transparency how
so so when Vietnamese coffee leaves
Vietnam the label doesn't say product of
Vietnam or Vietnamese coffee beans it
just says Coffee
with only Brazil outpacing Vietnam
exported about 3.5 billion pounds of
coffee in 2020 alone most of it mixed
into commercial grade Blends and while
Vietnam is the world's largest producer
of the Robusta Bean the vast majority of
high-end specialty coffee is Created
from a different species the Arabica
Bean what are some of the misperceptions
about Vietnamese coffee people wouldn't
use words such as cheap disgusting nasty
rubber tires to describe the Robusta
beam but really that experience or those
descriptions it's really rooted in the
production not the variety if you've
pushed an entire industry into an
instant cheap coffee production you're
going to get a lower quality product
because you're selling for a cheaper
product
a perception and process Roasters like
Nguyen and others are trying to change
by embracing the Robusta Bean robusta
beans have up to double the caffeine
content of Arabica robusta beans also
have up to 60 percent less fats and
sugars than Arabica so what that means
from a flavor experience is you'll get a
much more dark chocolatey nutty bold and
low acidic coffee with robusta beans
when coffee Supply is part of a
burgeoning shift as more specialty
Vietnamese coffee companies open around
the country well I think we're in the
very first early stages of Robusta as a
specialty uh beverage Jonathan Morris
the author of coffee a global history
says much of a rappica's appeal has been
in how it's processed with Robusta left
out of the picture what we're beginning
to see is well what happens if we try
those things with Robusta will that make
a bit of a difference will that create
some specialty beverage and with a
coffee
Morris calls the increased awareness a
new mindset and approaching that morning
cup of Joe this is a lot of thought to
put into a cup of something that you
normally drink uh when you're not
thinking that clearly yet
yeah there's a little thought involved
there's a little work involved but it
pays off uh you know it pays off for you
both in terms of what you taste and in
terms generally uh hopefully of what
you've achieved by your purchase and I
think that is something that is becoming
more and more important to Consumers for
Nguyen it wasn't just the mass-produced
Vietnamese coffee that left a bitter
taste in her mouth but how the farmers
themselves are impacted Vietnamese
coffee historically and currently has
always really been pushed into the
instant coffee Market or the cheaper
commodity to Coffee market and because
they don't have visibility
representation they can't really
advocate for better that inequality
became a driving force in starting the
company both of nguin's parents fled
Vietnam as refugees after the war but
most of her family still lives there
today a 2016 trip changed the course for
life when the then documentary maker
connected with a farmer and family
friend their idea to celebrate
Vietnamese coffee by cultivating better
beans my producing partner and other
Farmers I talked to they're like how
come we can't be a part espresso coffee
because the industry kept saying you
don't belong and so he had never
actually exported to United States he
felt so proud that his coffee beans made
it to America
today the beans roasted here are shipped
to all 50 states the company says the
revenue has grown by 24 times in just
two years Nguyen says she now partners
with three Farms paying workers a higher
rate for the more labor-intensive
process
[Music]
she's also hoping to import Vietnamese
coffee culture a slow paced ritual
influenced by French colonization one in
appreciation of every last drop in
Vietnam you actually eat breakfast first
and then you go to a coffee shop or or a
cafe standing you have your coffee alone
like it is its own moment the coffee is
traditionally made as a single serving
using a Vietnamese coffee press known as
a fin filter and served with sweetened
condensed milk
I love how easy it goes down
smooth yes it's very very smooth while
the company continues to roast and
refine the flavors of Vietnamese coffee
Rin goes beyond the drink it wasn't
about the coffee I mean it is but it was
really about this mission for me to
bring visibility representation to such
a historically marginalized community
and one that having completely rendered
invisible for its massive contributions
to the global coffee experience like I
saw there was an injustice there for me
to write through developing our own
supply chain and then of course through
storytelling and connecting people and
bringing people together through coffee
a community spanning thousands of miles
getting together over a cup of coffee
we stay in Brooklyn for our next
caffeine Caper or Jim Axelrod discovered
something special brewing in the back
room of a bodega
in the shadow of the Manhattan Bridge in
Brooklyn College sharafi is restocking
his supply of Colombian beans for the
coffee bar inside the grocery store he
runs with his cousin Omar Jaime
one black one cream sugar you guys have
lots of people coming in here right put
a coffee bar right up at the front yeah
and they're drinking Colombian right
yeah yeah that coffee but when it comes
to filling their own cups forget the
coffee bar no we have cigarette place a
secret place Speak Easy
the coffee Speak Easy yeah and in their
back room coffee speakeasy
where they brew It Old School
you can forget the Colombian beans as
well
what do you drink in the background
you have any coffee
Omar and Khalid are from Yemen which is
also home they say to the world's best
coffee
yeah Yemen coffee is the grandfather of
all coffees
how old is the tradition of coffee
drinking in Yemen so the coffee start in
the middle of 14th century Ibrahim
al-hasbani is an eighth generation
yemeni coffee merch low acid low acid so
it's it's not going to bother your
stomach it doesn't have f2tase and
there's a natural sweetness yes
do you think that is because of the soil
or the Sun or the kind of water all of
this is mixed in mixed them in a coffee
special he estimates there are as many
as 5 000 yemeni owned bodegas in New
York City just about everyone with a
back room where they keep the good stuff
so if I walked into their Bodega and
said can I get a cup of yemeni coffee
what would they say sicilium and coffee
no they said we don't have
but if you're friends with them maybe
they're going to give from the back
take the bodega monifs the odd runs in
East Harlem you order your coffee
where sure enough she wants black ice
coffee this is for you right
it's Colombian up front
but in the back
this is all yemeni cars all yemeni
coffee Ziad keeps half a dozen different
varieties in his back room brought by
friends and family visiting from Yemen
some more coarsely ground others not as
dark one so mellow it doesn't need milk
another so strong it'll knock your socks
off
like you know instead of to do double
shot from Starbucks or from Dunkin
Donuts you just use one shot for this
that's good no sugar no milk there's no
sugar no milk just black just straight
black so if the yemeni coffee is Top
Shelf
oh it's different
that's off the charts yeah
why not sell it up front
a civil war trout and spiking shipping
costs have sent yemeni coffee prices
soaring particularly problematic for
ahaspani one of the few to try taking it
from the back room to the front counter
opening up Kawa house a chain of yemeni
coffee shops what's it cost for you to
bring in a shipment of yemeni coffee
beans lots of mint has cost me around
four hundred thousand dollars wait wait
wait wait
your last shipment of how many coffee
cost you four hundred thousand dollars
yes if you were to get the same shipment
same size of Colombian beans what would
that cost you
sixty thousand
I don't know sixty thousand which is why
for the most part yemeni coffee is not
for the poor and go crowd
all right 350. and so for now just about
every yemeni selling coffee will keep
stocking the Colombian up front to Make
a Better Living
and continue to drink the good stuff in
the back
to make a better life it's legit isn't
that daily basis coffee for now but for
you is it yes
we'll have to check your ID before
serving up this next story we head to
California for a signature coffee
cocktail this is the dish
what could be more decadent and
delicious than fresh brewed coffee
topped off with a splash of whiskey and
a dash of cream
John Blackstone visits the Buena Vista
Cafe in San Francisco to see how they
mastered the iconic Irish coffee with
cable cars running past its door the
Buena Vista Cafe opened in 1916 is a San
Francisco institution and for over 40
years it's had the same bartender who's
been making the same drink that made the
Buena Vista famous how many Irish
coffees have you made in 41 years the
guesstimate they say four to five
million I just take their word for it I
didn't count them if anyone knows the
story of how Irish coffee first came to
America back in 1952 it's Paul Nolan
yeah the original recipe came from
Ireland the inventor he gave the recipe
to the beat writer for the chronicle
stand delophant so Stan delaplane who
introduced who brought Irish coffee from
Ireland to here
he was a newspaper guy he was a news he
was a reporter so is it proper for me to
say that maybe a news reporter is the
originator of Irish Coffee in America
rather than a bartender
well let's just say he can fade the uh
the recipe to the right source that
recipe Two Sugars
hot coffee and of course the active
ingredient this is about announcing the
third here of Irish whiskey then the
Finishing Touch carefully floating a
layer of heavy cream on top an
irresistible combination
and he tastes the whiskey it's dangerous
to do this with a mustache
usually we're giving an egg some napkins
mustache and nobody drinks only one Bob
Friedman admits he wasn't really an
Irish coffee fan when he bought the
Buena Vista back in 2001. at the time
they were doing about quarter million
Irish coffees a year a quarter million
Irish coffees a year yeah around that
number yes you made this because this
was a sound business decision not
because of Any romantic idea about Irish
coffee no I I like it it's a wonderful
dream matter of fact now I love it
and much loved by locals and tourists
alike there's no experience like being
at this table or at that bar and having
an Irish coffee at the Buena Vista
every week a truckload of Irish whiskey
arrives at the cafe enough to go through
a Hundred Bottles a day they say the
Buena Vista is the world's largest
single consumer of Irish
[Laughter]
not surprising given the way Paul Nolan
pours the stuff
and just in case I didn't give everybody
what they deserve I always add a little
bit more
for more stories like these and live
coverage of breaking news 24 7 stream us
right here on CBS News
I'm Jeff glor we'll see you next time
for another helping of the dish
this episode of the dish is sponsored by
Prudential plan invest insure retire
with Prudential